uh bert okay uh you know what's
something i really admire about you i
love that you
lean in
to your most viral moment
yes and you're you're proud of it you
you you honor it you want to celebrate
are you talking about the machine yeah
yeah like we've had these kind of
conversations before but i just love
that like some people like have a moment
and they run away
and they're like i don't want this thing
to define me when it's like these
moments always define you and you'll
have others that also define you etc but
they're so afraid of having that one
thing right i have theories i have
theories okay i have a theory that every
comic needs something big to pop once
and then a body of work behind them to
blow them up i think that and i think
yeah for uh
yeah bill burr is the philly thing
if
his thing goes viral everyone seems to
see the other thing and then they see
all the [ __ ] he's done but you need the
you need the body workout jeffrey's
punching the head right right yeah yeah
joe rogan carlos mencia yeah everyone
needs that pop for me it was that
machine story
and uh
and i
i got to be honest i was i was done
telling the story when i went back out
on the road so it goes viral like
six years ago on the 28th of december it
goes viral and it's and then i go to
vinnie brand's club
and it sells out and i and it was a
blizzard and i was like what the [ __ ] i
literally said on the thursday show why
are you guys here yeah cause i knew my
numbers right yeah yeah and they're like
the machine
and i was like oh i've retired that
story and they're like they'll [ __ ] you
out
and so
i kind and then the way i saw it i was
like okay well
this tour is in comedy clubs now these
are sold out they're all sold out we've
added thursday and sunday shows yeah two
on each and so there's more people that
have ever seen me so i'll tell it for
all the new people and then the next
time you go in and you're doing
two wednesday two thursday two friday
three saturday two sunday and then
adding and so i was like oh it's more
people well i'll tell it for the new
people and then you do theaters then you
do two shows a night of theaters then
you do bigger theaters then you do
arenas and then you're like well well
[ __ ] it's always more people and and and
i'll be honest with you i was with ari
and i'd look i still love ari but i was
with him and he was like don't tell the
[ __ ] story tonight i went you're
going to listen to what happens when i
don't and i go up and it's like all
right that's it and they start booing
and they're like tell the [ __ ]
machine and i'm like what all right and
so i tell it they go the second i say
when i was 22 years old i got involved
with the russian mafia they go [ __ ]
nuts and as long as they go nuts i will
be there because here's the other thing
not to get too inside baseball but i
think you guys get it
is
i also
was a failure in this business at one
point so i remember
thinking give me one thing give me one
thing to help me splash i i sat at the
ryman theatre and i watched angela
johnson perform she did two shows i was
with ari and nate pargotzi and and just
the three of us
and i said out loud to both of them
this is before the machine goes viral
give me one bit that is as popular as
her nail salon bit that i can sell out
the ryman twice
i will tell it every [ __ ] show i have
no problem with it i have no problem
with it now i'm doing two ryman's and
the grand old opera my first time in
nashville and you go hey man remember
what you wished for all you want is
people to come to your shows that's it i
every time i do a brand new hour i've
had this is my third hour on netflix
that i'm getting ready for every time i
do a brand new hour
the hours perform really well people
quote bits out of that but the machine
story i think yeah was just it was a
different
it was a different monster i mean i sold
i made a movie out of it yeah i'm i'm
merch tours yeah a nickname it's and i
go i'm not going to [ __ ]
i think it's great
what's the guy's name jimmy buffett
give me yeah dude i met jimmy buffett at
red rocks can you explain jimmy buffet
to people who probably don't know who he
is yeah i can't yeah crack one of those
okay [ __ ] jimmy buffett
is all of us
[Laughter]
we all have a little bit of greatness in
us and and and we're lucky enough if at
one point that greatness rears its head
and allows us to shine now for some kids
that's the gayest thing though from brad
radke brad ratchet playing baseball with
him right you ever play sports you box
right uh basketball basketball you ever
played with someone who goes pro uh
not pro but you sure good enough yeah
yeah right rocky i played baseball with
him every time he played everyone was
like there's something special about
that kid
and i remember wanting
everyone on our team wanted to be
special like him yeah yeah yeah and so
jimmy buffett represents that because
he put out
one album of just bangers
and then was like yup yeah i'll keep
writing but if you want to hear the hits
i am not better than you i'm here for
the hits now what is the song we all
know from jimmy buff well i'm a big
jimmy buffer fan so i could i could be
the average person uh cheeseburger
paradise margaritaville margaritaville
margaritaville i only know that line but
i know that but margaritaville is also
like a chain of dude like his business
[ __ ]
machine bars i'll do so margaritaville
is based around his song but it's also a
restaurant he owns
alcohol that's in it it's like an
experience built around who he is and
it's completely vertically integrated
he's leaned into this very successful
song and these people come to see him
they absolutely love him and
i i see inspiration of that with you and
i think it's awesome
and i was talking to derek poston who
opens for us hilarious comic and he went
to your show and he was like he gets it
in terms of show now i haven't seen your
show yet but like from the way he
described it you make the whole show a
show it starts before the show even
happens before show starts that's
something that we pride ourselves on
it's like when you walk in the video i
watch your i watch your videos so when i
see other people doing it i'm like okay
i'm like if i always look at people who
have success over a long period of time
and you just see them continually
growing that means the show is really
good
because those people can see a show and
then go okay i don't need to come back
and then the numbers dwindle we see
people have quick pops and all of a
sudden they're back playing one-nighters
when you see people continue to grow
they're delivering an experience
is you got to be in the moment you got
to love it yeah and you got to be you
got to be cool with failure because if
you're not cool with failure you're
never going to try new [ __ ]
and so like i've tried a lot of [ __ ]
that uh
that worked and didn't work and then i
just leave the stuff that works i mean
the perfect example is that drive a
movie theater tour yeah i came up with
that idea that looked amazing on video
but as a comic i'm like this would be
the worst possible way to perform
stand-up there are comics that did not
like it yeah however
i knew what i was offering so i was
offering was
an opportunity now we played some venues
like the amphitheaters were [ __ ]
amazing they're built for it
there's places that are built for it but
we went in and the first day we were in
north carolina it was in a rock quarry
and people
were getting to get out of their house
for the first time and live normal they
were all staying socially distant but
they brought smokers and grills and
couches and filled the bed of their
truck up with water brought hot tubs
yeah and they were getting to live
like like grading the [ __ ] tailgate
and have a blast yeah yeah we i said i
was gonna do four of them and i ended up
doing 35 cities 75 shows and
the experience that i saw was amazing
now were there times that it was not the
best show 100
yeah but
i'll never forget it and everyone that
went to them they go hey man i watched a
great comedy show but more importantly i
got out of the house when everyone was
locked in and i [ __ ] felt like i was
a part of a community communal
experience awesome dude
like you can talk to anyone nate
pargotti jim gaffigan brian regan they
all did them yeah and uh and and man
that first show i'll tell you it was
rough i got up i was i'd had an hour
ready and i did it in 35 minutes
i told the machine story twice
but but you got to be because i wanted
tom to do it with me yeah and tom was
like oh man i don't want i don't
want to be a guinea pig yeah and i was
like i'm cool with being a guinea i like
trying new [ __ ] yeah like i want
i want to i want
i don't know i like to learn from people
like when i watch
you guys like i don't think i'm not
watching you like a student where i go
like oh that's [ __ ] badass that's a
great idea now i'll never take anyone's
idea but if i if that inspires me to do
something yeah dude rogan look at rogan
my whole career is based off of me
meeting joe rogan in his house doing a
podcast and going this is [ __ ] sick i
want to do this yeah this is what i want
and then next you know i got two bears
one cave we have billbert uh [ __ ] you
name it and and and burt cast open tabs
and i go
i love being aspired from comics you
know yeah no it's great and that's the
cool thing like even that that machine
story like for those of you don't uh are
not familiar with it make sure you go
check it out it's got [ __ ] tens of
millions of views online i'm sure what
is it probably yeah 85 85 million
platforms yeah and like this is your
experience in russia and you got kind of
like
kidnapped a little bit got involved
and um
hard i was doing all the things this is
what's frustrating about this business
is you hear like you hear people go i i
hard work hard work you go oh you need
some luck yeah you need a couple of luck
yeah something to just happen where hard
works the foundation that luck is gonna
make all those plants start to grow you
plant all the seeds so there's got to be
this little bit of you know love
obviously for russia so you know we made
sure that we
got a couple things for you oh [ __ ]
start with the uh yeah so
um
since this experience in russia you know
changed your life we thought we'd get
you this shirt you know i love russia i
think that
i think that that's good that's really
cool yeah yeah they they
yeah there you go there you go there you
go you know there you go right there you
go so that's it
that's a good one
we also got we got
we got you this one this is a good one
too
this is good because of how much it's
changed your life and your family's life
and your kids
you know
we just thought yeah we just thought
that you would like this putin and a
bear obviously exactly like the two
bears the kids this is great this is
great
one bear one putin
one bear one dictator oh so we just got
some vodka in case you want to start
going probably your favorite vodka just
in case
is my favorite yeah and uh you know if
you would for whatever reason you get
cold during the podcast just something
again
that you could possibly wear
so glad that i'm here you know
i was hoping to get a splash on the
internet
[Music]
i mean russia's giving you so much vodka
hey does anyone have a clan hood
i'm not gonna throw one of those on real
quick
hey can anyone have any black face
real quick just touch up under my eyes
oh [ __ ]
this is the biggest mistake of my life
i'm editing that living thing out
tomorrow
welcome to the flanker 2 podcast we're
here with burke crusher
people accuse you of being a russian spy
oh well when i spent my time in dresden
after the war uh i was working with the
kgb and it just wasn't exciting and when
i was there
the soviet union changed so much during
perestroika that i thought this isn't
the russia i grew up knowing and loving
it that's right so i was like we need to
reclaim these outer places belarus
ukraine that's what i said yes yeah this
is your idea this is yours
this will get taken out of context
what's used on the other ones
they're going to be like by the way i
will [ __ ] tour russia hard as [ __ ]
i will be like [ __ ] five shows in
moscow at the
bolshoi ballet
guys thank you so much for watching that
clip from the flagrant two podcast and i
just need to let you know it is march
madness and the national championship is
up for grabs and so is the bag with my
bookie sign up today at my bookie and
use the promo code flagrant to secure a
first deposit bonus up to 1 000 it's
simple deposit 200 and play with 300
instantly just use the promo code
flagrant to claim your bonus mobile or
on the go college or nba no matter the
league no matter the minute my bookie
puts the action in your hands so you can
turn any game day into a payday bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie